قبل القيام بالرحلة ، كنت قد أعددت
نفسي لأشهد بعض الظروف اليائسة حقًا ،
لكنني لا أعتقد أن أي شيء كان
يمكن أن
يهيئني للموقف المؤلم الذي رأيته
هناك بشكل مباشر والروايات المختلفة
التي سمعتها من الأشخاص الذين تحدثت إليهم
في كل مكان  نظرت
حول بؤس المخيم وحدق في وجهك مباشرة
، أعني أنني رأيت عائلات كانت مكتظة
وملاجئ الخيزران الواهية أحيانًا
ما يزيد عن 50 60 شخصًا في ملجأ صغير
رأيته وإلا فقد
نصبوا خيامًا مؤقتة وكان الطين يتدافع الجميع
للحصول على مساحة نادرة
الموارد الغذاء والماء كان الأمر
مروعًا حقًا حيث رأيت حوالي 95٪ لا
يحصلون على مياه نظيفة ،
ثلاثة أرباعهم لا يحصلون على
ما يكفي من الطعام وبالطبع
الخدمات الصحية مرهقة جدًا
وفي كل مكان رأيت فيه الأطفال
كان هناك الكثير من الأطفال
وغالبًا ما يكون معظمهم في الواقع غير
مصحوبين بمقدمي الرعاية أو
عائلاتهم عندما تحدثت إليهم
سمعت أمرًا مروعًا  قصص عن كيف
رأوا أشقاءهم قد بلغوا أمهاتهم أو
آباؤهم يتعرضون لإطلاق النار أمام أعينهم ،
لذلك لا شيء يمكن أن
يهيئني للظروف الرهيبة التي
رأيتها هناك وأعمال العنف التي لا يمكن تصورها
والتي تم ارتكابها ضد
هؤلاء
الأشخاص حتى  قلت إنني سمعت عن
ركل الأطفال مثل كرات القدم
وسمعنا أيضًا أن هناك نوعًا هائلاً
ومزدهرًا من تحت الأرض كما تعلمون أن
سوق الاتجار بالجنس يحدث في
بعض تلك المعسكرات للأسف يبدو
أنه كان هناك
عمليات اغتصاب جماعي ممنهج لفتيات المدارس المحاصرات في
المدارس واغتصبن من قبل الجنود.
تحدثت إلى أحد عمال الإغاثة الذي أخبرني عن
فتاة تبلغ من العمر 16 عامًا تعرضت للاغتصاب 20
مرة وأيضًا عندما تحدثت إلى بعض
العاملين الصحيين هناك كانوا
يخبرونني  عدد المرات التي رأوا فيها
جروحًا في ظهور الأشخاص ، لذا
تم إطلاق النار عليهم في الواقع أثناء
محاولتهم الهروب ، لقد سمعت روايات عن
أم شاهدت
ابن أختها  تنقسم إلى أشلاء وألقيت في
النار ، لذا فإن هذا
الاضطهاد منهجي
لمجموعة من الناس أعتقد أنه ليس
أقل من التطهير العرقي الذي
يحدث هناك وهو فقط ما تعلم أنه
يتكشف أمام رؤية كاملة
للعالم وسيستمر  بلا هوادة وستستقبلك
حقًا
بقدر كبير من اللامبالاة ، قلت أيضًا
إنه إذا كان المسلمون هم
الجناة بدلاً من الضحايا ،
فربما تعرف ديترويت
أن الطاولات كانت ستقلب
وستكون هناك استجابة مختلفة جيدًا
انظروا إلى الاضطهاد ضد المنتقم الذي
لم يبدأ في أغسطس ، فهو
مستمر منذ عقود ، وأعتقد أنك
تعلم أن هناك شيئًا ما لهذا على مدى
العقدين الماضيين من
الأعمال الرهيبة لرجل أقلية اسمية من
المسلمين على هامش  في الواقع ،
نعتقد أن الإسلام جميعًا خارج
الإسلام قد أدى إلى زيادة المشاعر المعادية للمسلمين في
جميع أنحاء العالم والصور
النمطية السلبية عن المسلمين
لدرجة أن العديد  في جميع أنحاء العالم لا يمكن
حتى تصور المسلمين على أنهم
ضحايا ، ونعم أتساءل في بعض الأحيان
أنه إذا كان المسلمون هم الذين
ارتكبوا أعمال
العنف هذه ، ما إذا كان العالم
سيتفاعل بنفس اللامبالاة واللامبالاة